erdbeben in nepal die menschheit
fahrzeuge wie das himalaya weiter
aufgefaltet tausende starben und wurden
verletzt aber jetzt hilft moderne
satellitentechnik bei den
rettungsmaßnahmen
das ist dringend nötig denn nepal droht
eine hungerkatastrophe das thema jetzt
in klicks um science-fiction
25 april 2015 ein heftiges erdbeben
erschüttert das land die indische und
die eurasische erdplatte stoßen
aneinander und das schon seit millionen
von jahren immer wieder so bildete sich
das himalaya und das hochgebirge tibets
und jede bewegung dieser erdplatten
geschieht mit einem erdbeben
wir waren jetzt zeuge dieses geologische
mega ereignisses viele menschen sind
jetzt in not und brauchen dringend
ärztliche versorgung oder müssen
evakuiert werden und hier hilft jetzt
satellitentechnik das problem
große teile der ehemals vorhandenen
infrastruktur sind verschüttet oder
komplett zerstört
viele bereiche erreichbar noch nicht mal
mit dem hubschrauber
jetzt ist hilfe und aufklärung per
satellit gefragt dafür hat das deutsche
zentrum für luft- und raumfahrt dlr
anhand von satellitenbildern des
satelliten sentinel 1 mit der
unterstützung von us operations center
die bewegungen genauer analysiert daraus
ermittelten die forscher die größe der
verschobenen teile und das ergebnis das
ist dramatisch
eine 30 kilometer breite und 90
kilometer lange fläche bewegte sich in
wenigen sekunden mehrere meter das beben
hatte eine stärke von 7 8 an den
kollisionsstelle hob sich das erdreich
stark in blau im norden jedoch sank der
boden in gelb das ergebnis im norden von
kathmandu hob sich der boden über einen
meter im gegensatz dazu sank das
hochgebirge nepals großflächig um einige
zentimeter das heißt der mount everest
der höchste berg der welt ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich etwas niedriger
das zentrum für satellitengestützte
kriseninformation zki bietet einen
weiteren service an das max module
airborne kamerasystem das max ist ein
sogenanntes fernerkundung system max
umfasst viele unterschiedliche luftbild
kamerasysteme die man für ihren
speziellen einsatz vorbereitet hat vom
flugzeug bis zum quadrocopter schon
wenige tage nach dem beben wurden die
ersten referenzkarten der betroffenen
gegend vom zki an die
hilfsorganisationen übermittelt die
karten geben den rettungskräften einen
überblick und die möglichkeit
rettungswege landeplätze und weitere
planungs bedürftige schritte zu
organisieren die bilanz des erdbebens
ist bisher niederschmetternd nach
polizeiangaben starben etwa 6700
menschen und rund 14.000 wurden verletzt
die europäische union gab bekannt dass
man zu rund 1000 europäern keinerlei
informationen über ihren verbleib in
nepal hat nun gibt es erhebliche
beschwerden vonseiten der nepalesischen
bevölkerung an die behörden mängel wie
das der regierung langsam und
unorganisiert vorgeht und sie hilfsgüter
in eigenem interesse verteilt bewohner
kümmern sich größtenteils um sich selbst
und versorgen ihre dörfer mit
lebensmitteln und medikamenten
das erdbeben hat nepal tief getroffen
die folgen können noch verheerende
ausmaße annehmen beispielsweise eine
hungersnot
das kinderhilfswerk der vereinten
nationen teilte mit dass der zustand der
kinder besonders schlecht sei rund
15.000 kinder müssten eigentlich
aufgrund ihrer ernährungssituation auf
künstlichem wege ernährt werden
eine derartige katastrophe
verschlechtert die lager natürlich um
einiges im normalfall würden jetzt die
reisfelder bestellt werden
doch das wird wohl nichts folge daraus
ernteausfall ein solcher ernteausfall
könnte enormen lebensmittelmangel
auslösen
weiß ist das hauptnahrungsmittel in
nepal
wenn ein hauptnahrungsmittel fehlt kann
es passieren dass hunger leiden eine
noch stärkere rolle in nepal übernimmt
als eh schon und das würde eine
hungerkatastrophe bedeuten
die moderne technik hilft jetzt dabei
das schlimmste zu verhindern
trotzdem wird in nepal dringend hilfe
benötigt hier ist der link zur
spendenaktion der unicef unbedingt
mitmachen wahnsinn was die natur für
kräfte entwickeln kann wie man in 27
seiten den untergang einer zivilisation
berechnen kann das erfahrt ihr in dem
video hier droht der untergang unserer
zivilisation was denkt ihr
sollte die menschheit solche gebiete
meiden und sich gar nicht mehr ansiedeln
oder sind solche katastrophen ganz
normale begleiterscheinungen unserer
existenz diskutiertes in den kommentaren
und ansonsten bis dann bleib dran